Valerie is in San Francisco hi Valerie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
such a pleasure to be speaking with you
you too
what's up so just to start off with I am
a single mom I think about $72,000 a
year I have about I want to say forty
five thousand dollars in assets I want
to say about twenty four thousand
dollars in cash now my liabilities it's
forty four thousand completely ninety
thousand dollars if that includes a big
chunk of student loans
how much student loan debt student loan
debt do you have how much student loan
debt do you have it's fifty eight
thousand two hundred and twenty eight
thousand seventeen so what's the rest of
your day and the rest of like that is I
just bought a new car and I had to get
my car to my mother so and I had a small
loan on that for five thousand and in
the new car is twenty thousand now and I
only have about twenty three twenty four
hundred in credit card which if I stay
within budget and I follow your plan I
should be able to pay off both Carlos
tell me about the twenty fourth you have
twenty four thousand dollars in savings
but you said you had forty something in
assets what's the other assets the other
twenty two thousand it's full retirement
in a retirement account correct what a
401k oh my it's a 403 B I work for a
hospital gotcha okay which I haven't
been consistent in putting any money and
and since I started I've been listening
to you since um I want to say March so
okay what I would do I woke up in your
shoes is I would write a check today and
pay off the car and I would pay off your
credit cards right and in fact like I
said if I say in your plan I'll be done
in September and the only do not have
the last piece of fifty thousand
no you didn't listen okay what we teach
folks to do is take everything that is
not in retirement down to a thousand
dollars and I would pay off your car
today out of your savings account and I
would pay off your credit cards today
out of your savings account then you
have fifty eight thousand today left to
attack with a seventy thousand dollar
income and you get rid of that within a
little over a year and then you rebuild
your emergency fund
that's baby steps one two and three and
get some scissors and cut up those
stupid credit cards that's the program
that we teach is called the baby steps
that's what we tell people to do if
you're listening to the show you knew
that but you're holding on to that
twenty four thousand because it's your
little security blanket and there's
nothing wrong with having a security
blanket I want you to have one but I
don't want you to have one that is
delusional and it's delusional when you
have a twenty thousand dollar car that
you bought so that you could give your
mom a five thousand dollar car neither
of which you could afford to do because
you're broke and yet you feel okay
because you got twenty four thousand
dollars sitting in a savings account see
how this is screwed up you're in denial
and so I would either sell your car or I
would pay it off today if you're
unwilling to use this money to pay it
off today you should sell it today I
suspect that's going to be part
troublesome for you and I want it to be
I want you to feel the pain of this
because what you're doing right now is
normal stuff and you're broke and you
can't do normal and be anything but
broke it doesn't work